(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
- Whoa.
- [Kelly] So, say hi to Vanessa.
We were talking about "Ghosts" earlier.
- This is like a real life TV show.
- This is like a big deal.
- We're professional.
- Between "UglyDolls"
and "The Princess Switch"
by daughter is just losing
her (beep) back home.
- Oh my gosh, I love "UglyDolls."
That's amazing.
- I'm like,
I'm so nervous on behalf of her right now.
This is a big deal.
- It's transferred over.
- That's amazing.
- Oh my lord.
There's like so many princesses
that you switch with.
They all got different accents.
- There's the one where
there's like the three--
- Yeah, 35.
- I know I've seen them all.
- I don't how many, separated at birth.
- [Vanessa] I don't even know either.
I lost my mind during it so (laughing).
- That has to be fun though
playing different characters of yourself.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
Different versions, yeah.
I mean like 'cause as actors
like we're always playing
different versions of ourselves.
- Nope, I just get hired
just for the one thing.
- Nope.
- Okay, well.
- [Kelly] Just for, I can't see "Ghost."
- No range here.
(Vanessa laughing)
- Wait, do you believe in ghosts?
Or do you believe in them?
- Yeah, but I don't
believe in like malevolent
like ghost stories.
I believe like, you know,
our better angels are there
- Oh, okay.
- and they're with us
and they take care of us.
- Oh, you don't believe in,
yeah, mean ghosts.
- No no no, mean scary ghosts
I feel like we could talk to
and sort of like, you
know, negotiate with.
(Kelly laughing)
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah, I get that, I get that.
- Be like, yeah, don't
watch me while I shower
and I'll stay out of your space.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- Or watch me while I shower.
You're welcome.
Yeah, yeah, you're welcome.
- Depends on the mood.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I suppose.
- I suppose.
- I can't see you watching
me so whatever (laughing).
It's like.
So tell...
I just invited every creeper to my house
- I know, I was like...
(Vanessa laughing)
- subtly, and I didn't mean to do that.
- I was like I can't engage
with this conversation anymore.
- [Kelly] You're like I'm actually out.
- I was like where's my parachute?
(Kelly laughing)
- Tell us about "Ghosts" though.
By the way, my musical director
is obsessed with your show.
- Oh cool.
- Yes.
I just needed to tell you that.
- Thank you, thanks a lot.
- Yes, he's obsessed.
He was like I love this
show, I love this show.
I was like I'm gonna tell him.
- We just, we got super lucky.
Our cast is great and our creators.
It's about a couple, Rose
McIver and myself, Sam and Jay,
and we move into this
mansion in upstate New York
and it's haunted by a variety of ghosts
who I can't see but Rose can.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Utkarsh] And we sort
of, the hilarity ensues.
It's a family comedy about the undead.
Oh, and those two guys.
Look at that.
(Kelly laughing)
You guys are like top
notch production here.
- I'm telling you, super professional,
season three.
- Guitars on the wall.
This is the real deal.
- Season three.
I can't play them well but they're there.
Okay, so wait, so you were
in "tick, tick...BOOM!",
both of you.
So, you also did freestyle
rap though right?
- Yeah.
- You were in a freestyle
with Lin-Manuel right?
- Yeah, so Lin and I--
(crowd cheering)
Yep, yep, Lin.
- That's amazing.
- He doesn't need anymore praise, okay?
He's fine.
That guy's okay.
- That's how you know
you're close friends.
- Yeah, yeah, all right, enough.
All right, yeah.
We don't need to talk about him anymore.
- I know, but I want to talk about you
'cause at the Oscars,
it was in 2020 right?
That you did the freestyle?
- Right, yeah.
- So you love freestyling
or does it make you nervous to do that?
- That was like, yeah, it was terrifying.
But it was really fun.
- Oh, okay.
- We took this party trick
and we ended up on Broadway.
We won a special Tony for
it and yeah, I got to rap.
(crowd cheering)
- That's so cool.
- Shoutout to Sandy Lion
who designed that suit.
Um, yeah, we got to rap
and Brad Pitt was there
and he gave me a big old Brad Pitt smile
and I was like well, now
we're best friends and--
(Kelly laughing)
- Now we are BF's.
- Can you imagine
if we were best friends?
It would be so cool.
(Kelly laughing)
But no, we've never spoken to each other.
- But you made eyes.
- It was super fun.
But um...
- But you had a connection.
- We took this party trick,
we performed at the Tonys.
You know, I could maybe try
and do something for you guys now.
- Yes.
(crowd cheering)
- I want to see it.
- Yeah.
- Wait, so you just like
out of nowhere like...
(crowd cheering)
Okay, okay.
- Hey.
- Okay.
- What was your local mall.
- Local mall, Hulen.
- Hulen?
- Hulen Mall.
- Hulen.
- And what was your favorite
like food at the food court.
- Local, it was like 40 minutes away
but yeah.
- Yeah, I know how it works.
- It was a small town.
Food?
- Food court.
What would you eat at the food court?
- I didn't eat at the mall.
I was poor.
I just window shopped.
(both laughing)
- What did you eat at the food court?
(crowd laughing)
- Panda Express.
- Oh, okay, okay, okay.
- Favorite dish?
- It was like orange chicken.
- Yeah.
- You better believe it.
Okay, and now for both of you,
first CD that you ever got.
CDs are a compact, don't worry about it.
(Kelly laughing)
- I was gonna say probably
Boyz II Men, Motownphilly.
- Love it, and...
- Spice Girls.
- Nice.
(crowd cheering)
- What was the first one?
Spice Up Your Life?
- [Utkarsh] Spice World?
- Spice Up Your Life?
Spice World?
- Spice World.
You know what?
- We'll just say Spice Girls.
- We'll just...
Give me a...
Were you guys,
yeah, let's just do
something like (beatboxing).
(band playing groovy music)
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
♪ Yeah ♪
- Okay.
♪ Uh hew ee, uh hew ee, uh hew ee ♪
(groovy music)
♪ Now once upon a time not long ago ♪
♪ Before the Idol and
the Kelly Clarkson Show ♪
♪ Yeah, my girl, what was she doing ♪
♪ Going to the mall, yeah,
it was called Hulen ♪
♪ What's she there for ♪
♪ She there to window shop ♪
♪ 'Cause she's oh so poor ♪
♪ Oh yes, oh yes, out
West my Girl Vanessa ♪
♪ Was over at the Panda Express ♪
♪ Looking so good ♪
♪ Yeah, she finger licking ♪
♪ Go up to the counter
get that orange chicken ♪
♪ What ya doing me, you see ♪
♪ I'm Boyz II Men
listening to Motownphilly ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Oh so nice ♪
♪ I'm on the mic ♪
♪ And I'm crazier than
Scary Spice and Ginger ♪
♪ Head bringer, I am the bringer ♪
♪ I'll do it all day long ♪
♪ That's right, I never linger ♪
♪ I'm here Mr. Indian ♪
♪ So full of melanin ♪
♪ I rock up on the microphone ♪
♪ I came to spit without the pen ♪
♪ But anyway, I think I'm done,
I'm broken and I'm beautiful ♪
♪ That was my musical ♪
(crowd cheering)
- Oh my gosh!
That's actually crazy!
(crowd cheering)
- "Tick, tick...BOOM."
- That is actually crazy.
- "The Princess Switch"
now airing on Netflix.
- Utkarsh Ambudkar ya!
- Thank you guys.
(crowd cheering)